un axe
[Musique]
g
voilà
[Musique]
c'est en sport source et joseph
soit
l'accès
[Musique]
et
le faire passer de chanteurs de rue à
québec et devenir le grand gagnant
difficilement les grands et c'est un
grand gagnant assez relax à seebach ils
sont vraiment fait les gagner mais son
nom d'artiste le panda effectivement
quel beau parcours il a 29 ans multi
instrumentiste pendant des années de
donner des spectacles dans les rues de
québec
et hier soir il a remporté les grands
honneurs ce festival de la chanson de
granby et ça ça veut dire quarante mille
dollars en prix et en bourses
sa musique c'est un mélange de soul de
reggae de r'n'b de jazz il disait c'est
la première fois que je travaille avec
un directeur musical avec un metteur en
scène ce danger restait lui sont
maintenant sa vie son directeur musical
de québec
et là il se dit même si peut-être le
temps d'accrocher mon permis d'amuseur
public
je pense que personnellement c'est toute
l'expérience que j'ai eue dans la rue
l'expérience que j'ai eue avec les
imprévus avec les gosses ou qui vont
devoir petit des conneries puis il faut
tirage est ce assez rapidement avec les
parties pour pas pourquoi propres à
chaque état foule pour pas choquer les
gens qui t'écoutent fait que tout ça ça
me ça me permet d'être à l'aise sur
scène de pouvoir diluer avec n'importe
quoi car éviter que ce soit un enfant
qui crie danse à l'outil les gens
tapaient des mains et ont tapé tout le
long mais jeter sa main juste promet
encore plus il ya un nouveau directeur
au festival de la chanson de granby et
jean-françois lippé qui a été pendant un
bon bout de temps lui aussi à québec le
directeur des communications du musée
des beaux-arts du québec et qui se
souvient d'avoir vu le grand gagnant de
cette année son premier gagnant du
festival
ce que j'en pense mais je pense que
c'est une artiste que sa particularité
est lui sain ses singularités pardon à
lui donc c'est un artiste multi
instrumentiste une très belle voix qui
qui qui va de sa compagne et lui même
donc c'est un artiste complet
le panther que j'ai que j'ai même croisé
dans les rues de québec
quand j'habitais à québec donc je suis
bien content pour lui je compte aussi
pour les autres je pense que compass
officer la chanson de granby c'est une
belle carte de visite donc les 24 demi
finalistes doivent être tous est très
fier aussi de crier aux et d'interpréter
des chansons en français encore
aujourd'hui oui vraiment toujours de
grands artistes
c'est un mur sorte d'effet c'est vrai il
ya eu dix ans le blanc il a eu du mal de
larochellière et luce dufault
festivement effectivement et donc
d'autres artistes se sont démarqués
notamment prix de la meilleure présence
sur scène a été décerné à un duo assez
original mais merci leurs visages sont
masse qui s'appelle classement donc ils
ont reçu une bourse de 1000 $
l'important pour eux c'est justement de
se faire remarquer que vous vous
souvenir des autres
voici l'extrait de leur prestation
d'hier soir
[Musique]
parce que là
pourquoi
je
mais en fait classe mode nous on
des chansons comme ça en fait donc on
travaille beaucoup sur la mise en scène
tout se décrire d'un couteau on vient de
la planète loisy ce sont des venu sur
terre pour en fait donné un message
d'amour aux gens parce qu'on a on pense
que aujourd'hui les gens ont besoin de
beaucoup d'amour on est là pour ça dans
nos textes dans notre approche donc les
classes moitié ces spécialistes d'amour
à surveiller au classement certaines
influences de daf pas une car je pense
dans leurs locaux
enfin pour ce qui est du prix du public
et bien ça a été décerné à musique à un
groupe de musique traditionnelle de
grandes baies 3 musiciens qui ont de 18
à 24 ans la croiser dans ta donc on leur
souhaite à eux et aux autres ne belle et
longue carrière jamais
[Musique]